I had a fan asked me in San Diego to
sign this poster I sell these posters
and he I said what's your name Annie I'd
talked to Tyler Tyler Tyler and then I
wrote to Tyler yes and he loved it he
lost a lotta Studdard yeah what do you
think I was no because yeah oh no no no
no he was I thought maybe he was nervous
and maybe no he said why are you
laughing at that he could have been
nervous you did it again
wow that's fun I wrote to ddddd Euler
yeah I did the guy who stuttered really
had a hard times with T's - yeah that's
the hard work for some reason team
endearing [ __ ] like a champ did he
have a pumpking huh yeah he was like
real strong and like his his his his sex
didn't match his vocal ability right
yeah so he had what else tell me more
about his strengths I was really small I
call him little Herc little hurt so he
could pick you up by your ass cheeks and
[ __ ] you in the sky like [ __ ] you
standing up yeah I was really really
impressed that's hot because he was so
weak in all other aspects of life right
but face-fucking was unbelievable
unbelievable right yeah tell me more I
want to know about all the things that
he could do what was his favorite
position um what was it what was your
favorite position with him with little
Herc I I wouldn't call it a position I
would call him more I probably what we
call like the helicopter oh right yeah
yeah where he was real strong so you sit
on his penis and he can just spin the
cornish Carl I'm spinning my pussy's on
his face oh my god I didn't know that
was that work on the split whoa
so his tongue is bouncing your click yes
are you doing like a helicopter report
from like live from the sky exactly what
I'm doing yeah there's no traffic down
there whatsoever it's clear I know I've
had enough time 90 minutes we're already
at a 90 minute nowhere rom-com right now
this a rom-com I've never done 90
minutes I don't think like that free
that fun that's pretty good really good
really really good you know you know why
I know you know why we would get
chemistry because kalila and I do very
well together
I had to add one more piece of
information is it a little hurt do you
know where I met him I met him you know
how you take Bobby it Oh what do you
have with that class he had to take
speech 101 you have to take that in
college right it's like that's where I
met him he was taking the speech because
he was like and you were like this guy's
yeah like I'm gonna [ __ ] that one that's
the one I want
Wow yep you want me to touch your [ __ ]
kalila I wanna put my tongue in your
[ __ ] anyway shot was that dude Tyler
I appreciate the [ __ ] out of all the
fans too I want to say was that was very
nice I appreciate those humans so very
very much
considers become actors probably not on
uh there have had been one or two that
have existed but they call me partisan
we can only play someone the stutters I
guess I used to everybody I had a buddy
with a terrible stutter but when he was
on stage or when he was like yeah he
would stop even though it would go away
oh wow off stage or off camera whatever
he he would you go through that moment
he was on stage he was so fluid and
clear it's like uh it took away his
anxiety yeah it was really weird it was
like adderall how it does different
things for different people
yeah he was faking it like a preparation
no I'm saying like maybe if he knows his
lines like oh yeah maybe if it's not
yeah maybe one stand up he would do
stand all he was doing Stan yeah he just
could just kind of go
it's it's like I saw a sometimes I like
watching religious programs years and
you know when I was in high school I saw
this Benny Hinn you know he is oh yeah
so Benny Hinn was doing his thing you
know peak Auditorium what is it he's
like a mega pre mega preacher right and
he heals people so there was this old
lady Ryan
you know wheelchair and she had chronic
arthritis like she hadn't stood up in 15
years not because she can't it just hurt
so bad yeah it's painful it's so painful
she's bound to a wheelchair so he's
saying that he cured right and she gets
up it's break dancing really good you
know it's so painful what she's doing
she's in she's going yeah but she her
belief in God his strong association
much stronger than plain you know be
that she the worst is when penny hit and
goes you have cancer and because yeah
it's in my liver and he goes like this
he goes hit it threw it on the ground
there it is on the ground and the guy
looked at it went right i probably died
too much later guys what am i that [ __ ]
is the worst [ __ ] scandalous [ __ ]
i've ever seen well you saw this guy
what was this guy this preacher that
they had on the that had all these
private jets and they call them out on
Inside Edition or whatever oh my god you
look like the clip is amazing she's like
how come you're flying all over the
country a private jet seems like it
takes a lot to preach the war to god
baby don't [ __ ] look at all he's got
these big devilish eyes he's like this
it takes out you've seen it huh you see
this guy what's this really enabled one
of those named that Joel preacher Jean
is also a dick because never in that
whole Austin flooding happened and he
had like all this space to allow people
in he didn't either actually the worst
thing is Bobby I think I told you about
this the worst one I've seen in a long
time Tina :
Kenneth told Kenny coach Ken Ken
Copeland
[Music]